july is fast approaching the start of
flash flood season in the valley the
flood control district reminding
everybody about the dangers first don't
drive through flooded streets turn
around and don't drown cars can be swept
away quickly in fast moving water steer
clear of detention basins channels
washes and storm drains and water can
flow through these areas at up to 30
miles per hour again it only takes six
inches of rushing water to knock you
down
pool again safety is key because
flooding can happen when you least
expect it now the regional flood control
district is laying out plans to protect
you during these situations
floods can happen at any time of the
year without warning
as flash flood season rolls in clark
county is trying to stay ahead of the
game to keep southern nevada residents
safe around the valley about 75 percent
of the regional flood control district's
master plan has been completed that is
the areas in blue the red marks are the
areas still in progress
since the mid 1980's about 680 miles of
storm channels and over 100 detention
basins have been built taxpayers
spending 2.16 billion dollars and
improving more than 60 square miles of
land that have been removed from flood
zones
as the rain season approaches the race
is on to get as much of these 47
projects completed including the blue
diamond wash the meadows charleston
storm drain and the gowan el capitan on
centennial parkway drone video shot by 8
news now shows fort apache and warm
springs just one of many projects across
clark county that officials hope will
keep residents safe
tomorrow clark county officials and the
regional flood control district are
expected to give an update on all of
these projects